perfect so hi welcome so nice to see so
many of you here and I know it's a bit
late you're tired hungry thirsty but I
promise you guys that the presentation
is going to be quite cool
maybe fun and easygoing so please enjoy
and do not use your phone because I'm
going to get angry so focus on these and
these and please try to learn something
so my name is one and I'm a software
engineer Patera at Levu and at la who I
work with spammers I'm data every single
day and in this talk I want to talk to
you guys about that spammers and the ADA
and how we are fighting them so let's
begin with a little bit of context so
logo is a dating app and a social app
meaning that we have a lot of pretty
people who are trying to engage in to
some sort of activities with other users
however I got some bad news
because the world is not a perfect place
and you guys know that whenever you have
real users there's going to be spammers
that's the fact you have emails you have
spammers you have web services you have
bombers spammers are everywhere now
the goal of these filthy and horrible
spammers at least in our goal is to use
the app to advertise other platforms and
to try to scum other users and this hell
they look like don't focus on the
numbers I don't care about them but I
want you guys to see the ups and down
one day I could be winning the fight but
the next day the spammers are going to
come with a new technique and then the
numbers are going down and then this
farmer comes by and the numbers change
so they evolve the spammers evolve
because they are constantly trying to
bypass and with our systems but I do the
same you know I'm not going to be
stealing they're just like looking how
the spammers are going to destroy the
whole app so I also need to get my stuff
together so it is some sort of fight
here is a fight in which my main weapon
is data so in this thought my purpose is
to present to all of you what all the
tools the algorithms are the
architecture that were using to fight
all these powers of
course to avoid the proliferation of
them in the platform they my agenda for
today first I'm gonna talk a little bit
about this panel itself their
architecture how to see looks like then
I'll be talking about data machine
learning an algorithm which is the cool
part and then at the end some numbers
and lastly unfortunately I need to end
this presentation so then the recap so
at this time the Spanish level solution
to detect and to block spammers and if
uses a mix of machine learning and
heuristics to identify the spamming
profiles and at the spam oops it is not
a modern epic 16 it is actually made of
over 15 components it is reading in : I
know it's quite strange considering this
is a Python conference but I'll talk
about Python soon and lastly it is
amazing my opinion might value rapid
bias but I'm sure is really cool and
this is our stack we use go it's our
main premiere language in the system
then we just Google cloud now I'm going
to sound like a Google cloud sailor
because I'll be mentioning this a lot
but the fact is that the whole platform
runs in the cloud
everything everything plus we use a lot
of the features from the cloud
lastly we use Kafka and cafes our main
engine to move things around and the
last thing is package called coca invoke
a solid Robbie an open-source package
for : that we wrote in how to interface
cough castle coca go car of Kafka 3
forward but now what about a rope we
have Python of course square here and
these are the thing that we used to
train our system we have scikit-learn
everybody no sir kara tensorflow
and in that tiny corner you can see our
because we use our most before Anna
analyzing our data but now the
architecture how the still looks like
once again at this Bank is a platform
made of over 15 components and at its
center
we have Kafka and Kafka is going to be
the mean of communication between all of
them
and we interface Kafka using coca which
is a co-op resource library and in Kafka
we're going to keep our life data so we
don't use
any databases for this everything here
is turning Kafka why well because it's
fast and most importantly we need to do
this in real time because if there's a
spammer now I need to get this farmer
today not tomorrow and even make uses of
Mary product platform and lastly it runs
on kubernetes and you and this is how it
looks like so for me here on the left
side we can see the client the app the
user on his phone doing so every single
time the user does something fun
something cool it's going to trigger one
message one event and this event will be
sent to the back end or this event is
going to create some changes in the
database which is this one here this is
called spanner and also this event is
going to be sent to pop so then after
pops up there's some magic process which
is going to take the pops on message and
convert it into Kafka message
I mean Kafka this is where the magic
happened guys made of a lot of topics we
have found 96 95 topics in Kafka and
these are the components of anti-spam
they have funny names
sheriff terminate or photo referral
process and so on and every single of
these components is clean it is going to
apply one particular technique is one of
this component is going to try to find
if the user who trigger this event is a
spammer or not
so these components are going to start
consuming all this to me from Kafka to
you to it all of them and they're going
to do some magic calculation and if the
component believe that this user should
be punished it's going to send something
called an advice to this little guy here
called the meat grinder now meeting I
like to call him meat is going to take
the advice and it's going to be like ok
shoot this person be punished yes or no
and it's going to go through a lot of
rules you know for example is going to
shake if the user is equality listed
because for example my profile is quite
listed because I shouldn't be punished
and then if the answer is yes then we're
going to trigger the punishment this
punishment is going to the back end and
the person is going to get up horrible
notification on his phone saying like
you have been kicked out of the app but
what's going on here
to see our model training section here
is what the magic happens so all this
data eventually goes to bigquery and
bigquery is some sort of say is our peak
data warehouse and from here we're going
to load our data
you seem Python and then we're going to
train our models you see in scikit-learn
chaos or whatever
lastly after the model is being trained
is going to be stored into cloud storage
and once the model is storing clothes
storage each component is going to
retrieve the model and thing is going to
make it run into production under the
story I'm going to give more details
soon about it but now the cool part is
what we like so please get your papers
your yeah pension rights on so algorithm
we employed going on this pan who used a
mix of machine learning a heuristic to
be taken to fight the spammers now the
data that we use is based on different
since text count images as sequential
data and so notice algorithm are created
by scratch bios all trained using carrot
or psyche learn but now a resistor with
data right perfect
yeah of course and this is how we get
the data into anti-spam we have three
main sources of data the first one is a
low back end the user
okay anyway so let me go back so we have
three main sources of data sorry I mean
the first one is going to be the back
end and here the user is going to do
something in the app and then it's going
to trigger one event and even go to pop
so second with an airflow running air
flow we have different jobs that are
going to run every single night and it's
going to generate some aggregation of
data for example and then we have an TSP
now this bang is going to produce Sun of
its own Zahra why because we like to
keep track of everything that at least
Pandora's because it helped us in the
future to develop new things but how do
we do this well we have a tiny guy here
it's called the barbecue and barbecue is
the only is the only source of
information that is going to get to take
data from and this one is going to store
it into bigquery
it's called barbecue because big queries
big Hugh and vbq I don't know like
Barbie barbecue stuff like that so this
is the only guy the only component was
coming to talk to the outside but then
now that we have the data they were able
to learn from it and these are our
boring components the basic ones start
the heuristic based one and the first
one is the Terminator and the Terminator
is basically just a bunch of rules if if
if if you come from a px if you are from
this country if you if I don't like you
then you get punished then we have the
behavior rules and in the ruse is
another set of if but it's more based on
the behavior or how the user is using
the app for example if our users are
female does 15 castilian bolt in one
minute might be about you know because
the girls don't do that and we have the
community and the community deals with
the report if a person gets ten reports
in less than five seconds come on of
course three of you some jealous farmers
so you will receive one punishment but
not the cool one yeah yay
machine learning base unless release a
small story as farmers and most farmers
they behave in different ways for
example one female
she could login do one like send one
message reject all the votes in the
platform because that's how they work
right but a spammer user she will try to
contact every single person in the app
so in conclusion they behave in uncommon
ways and for this we got our first
person here of the our first friend and
it's called the sheriff and the sheriff
is the user behavior model and this this
thing is going to classify user between
spam and a spammer based on their
behavior and the features that we use
here describe the user execution ratio
of events some confusing but give me one
second and so far currently today the
model is one logit regression model
train using scikit-learn with a dataset
of
over 1 million and around 30 feature
that's today several month ago will you
sing a random forest but we decide to
change because changes are nice right
and this is how the training set looks
like this is like a screenshot of it and
here we have the columns on each column
represent one event something that the
user is going to execute message sent
like even three and so on and the last
column we have the label so what is
happening here is that the first user
the first row is telling me that 33% of
all the events that the user has done in
the last X hours can see the numbers
because the spammers are watching me
that a story that means that 33% of the
event has been message sent 33% of the
event has been like so the user has some
kind of really normal amount of events
you know everything seems to be the same
so the user might know bit a spammer is
done zero but let's talk about the third
user here we see that the third user
100% of all the event he or she has
executed has been even three so the user
might be as farmer so of course the
label is one and the person will get
punished so now let's move on from that
and in our app there are two fields in
which the user can actually write any
text they want and this is the username
field of course because people has name
and the about me and this is what you're
right like are like traveling and like
food I mean who doesn't
so of course spammers are going to use
these fields because farmers like other
stuff
and this is an example an example of a
username some user might be called sexy
me called one two three four plan a plan
nine or another spammer might write and
he's about me example and he about me
field interested in hosting me sex yes
send me an email to XS x HH a double d
double D I forgot the last one F add hot
steamy sex come
I was actually practicing that so for
doing this for telling with these text
we came up with Rosetta another OC for
me roses I can only get like 60 years
old so Rose is a component maze of
several test related models and they
input of this model is going to be of
course text and once again here why you
seem legit trainee scikit-learn and to
give more detail about them we have two
different kind of models the about me
and they were about usernames and
recording the about me we have one model
per country because we have different
languages right so we realize that it is
more work to have won multiple country
but it works better and the training set
is various here we have form around
40,000 case to a hundred thousand case
observation and the data person step is
quite straightforward we lower case
everything could remove the stop war we
filter some rows and the way back to
write the text regarding the other one
in the username is quite similar but so
far we only have one model we might
change this in the future and the
training set is don't is greater from
around 15k here less than before today
there are proposing step is similar is
said that we use a bigram here and we
use by character level diagram so we are
going to separate each character into
grams so it's quite similar and let's
talk about images no more checks and
just suppose that you are pledging in
the app you know scrolling scrolling and
you see this picture picture of tennis a
handsome person and you highlight these
texts again interesting ostomy says and
you're like Jesus Christ is people I
gain so of course it makes me angry at
least it makes me really angry so for
this we came up with this to guy s
Porter and the photographer and the gold
of this body and photography is to deal
with
images and the spotter is going to
detect it only detect e-text on the
images
remember detection and the photo refer
is going to extract the text and this
text is going to be sent to the
Terminator the first guide that I
mentioned before and the Terminator is
going to determine if the person is good
or bad based on the text because we have
a lot of rules in the Terminator and the
spotter ring in pythons actually I will
only speak may your system that is
actually running in production in Python
and we just open CV for the detection
and the extraction part is going to be
done by Google television API and they
see how the whole system looks like it's
a bit confusing polyester from the
bottom left so here we have first the
user is doing something in the phone - -
- - he wants to upload one image this is
going to trigger one picture upload
event this event is going to Kafka and
then Kafka is going I mean then the
spotter is going to acquire this event
and we're going to top his cloud storage
we're going to retrieve a picture the
picture goes back and then we check if
there is text if the answer is yes only
the answer is yes we're going to create
one text detected event this event is
going to Kafka and then the photographer
is going to consume this event and once
again we're going to retrieve the image
from cloud storage we're going to
communicate with low vision API
uncle vision API is going to tell us if
there is text if the answer is yes go to
the Terminator and read a text is bad
the person will get punished now why are
we doing this well money cost in an
optimal world we would send every single
image straight to Google cloud but you
know I think the price is quite high
it's like 150 every thousand images and
we deal with like billion millions and
millions of images so at the end it's
really really expensive so we rather
first here just only check if the person
actually has text and if the answer is
yes then we send the picture to Google
so now they missed off the cool things
here and the first one is the tracer and
the tracer with its fancy name it's that
component that tells we seek when
and the tracer tries to answer the
question how is the user using the app
what is the order of events executed by
the user and its goal is going to be to
detect the spammers based on their
sequence of events which we call actions
and the model is one RNN train with
launcher term Memorial STM unit and also
train in Kara's now let's raining
snowing Google Cloud ml why it's quite
straightforward we don't actually need
to to start machine with like a billions
GPU and so on we simply to the script
we all wrote the script we click start
and then the whole train is going to be
done automatically in Google also the
model is served in Google so we don't
have to have an extra machine just to
serve them all were simply using the
tools that Google is providing us I know
I'm talking about Googlebot and this is
how they look like please follow me here
we have three different kind of action
in the tracer the active one and the
active are the action that the user
executes I like a person I send you a
message that we had the passive one and
the passive are the events that are done
upon me you like me you write me and so
on then we had the third one and the
other one is the time pocket now here
we're going to take how much time the
time difference between these events and
the previous one and we're going to Boca
ties this into some sort of actions so
meaning that we don't actually keep the
exact time we simply pocket like this
for example if it is the first action we
write the number one if it has been from
zero to five seconds we use the number
two and so on and they see how they
looks like this is an example of one
sequence the first one means like the
the time in me like number one means
that is my first action the one in blue
are the active one and the one in
capital letter or orange are the passive
one so this user the first event was
alike then after after zero or five
seconds
they died like they once again II got a
like button around 20 or one minute
after that like the person got a dislike
and this is even cooler right they say
how they look like am i right
I have unknown spammer I don't LF i has
a spammer now the white colour as he
actually an image that represent the
action so it's better for us to know how
they look like the white one means the
passive event the event that I don't
upon me so the non spammer has received
a nice amount of images
I mean someone of likes or messages then
we have the green one and the green ones
are the messages so the no spammer
person this both cases are female sorry
she lock in she sent some messages maybe
she has like one friend to friend for
friends I don't care and then we see all
that red what a red can anyone guess
dislikes so this person decide to
dislike a billion people here and blue
are the likes so maybe there were some
likes here across between all these
dislike now the spammer this guy
Jesus Lord he's only going to like every
single person likes why I don't know but
here we can see that the person is going
to like and then messages and it very it
does so many events so quickly that it
doesn't have time you know it feels the
bother of events so quickly and you
barely see any white event because they
are so so fast and currently so far
we're only using 500 events 500 like the
sequence that's a mass of 500 because
it's quite expensive to keep all this
data in Kafka we try to keep the
messages in Kafka under 1 megabyte and
between all the sequences and the dice
time and this and this information we
have around 600 kilo watt per message so
we need to keep it slow or the white
Kafka is going to crash and my neck also
might crash because if I could have cut
the whole company goes down but now our
last experiment this one is called the
conviction and the conviction is a meta
model I like to call it that uses the
scores of all the other components some
confusing right but the features are
going to be the confidence value of the
other components sherry Rosetta tracer
and so on and we had this crazy theory
you know the theory that I do this cause
when you are the bathroom
the whole way in the elevator that maybe
maybe by using combinations of all these
components we might lead to more
punishment because sometimes when one
component could be almost about to
polish someone but what about if I look
at the scores of this one and this one
then I might be able to punish you and
currently is indefinite but it would
probably be another logic random forest
or just a bunch of heuristic produced by
hand and this is an example of a
training set here each row corresponds
to one of our components
the first one is tracer sherry username
and so on and in the first user we can
see that he actually all the scores are
quite low
the minimum is zero the maximum is one
so this person might be a normal user
but the second person point 65 75 point
five so there's something a bit fiji
here so the user might be a spammer so
we're just going to punish the user on
whatever then s1 is quite obvious the
person has a 99 percent in the tracer
and I work current threshold is 995 so
indeed is going to be a spammer and the
last person is the same he has 80
percent like 2.80
in the Rosetta username but now the
Borgo reason let's move on to something
more interesting maybe and this is the
automatic training howto we keep track
of all this distance personally I can't
do it by hand every single day because
it takes a lot of time effort energy and
so on so we designed a really simple and
cool pipeline that is going to train and
reload some of these models now this is
the important part here please keep in
mind we only apply this to their mothers
that we fully understand and that do not
represent the high risk why oh just
imagine that we train once this thing at
2 a.m. this is think it automatically
deploy in production and when I go to
the office the next morning I realize
that on my system block the whole user
base
bad news right then I have to pick up my
stuff and go home however this how it
looks like quite confusing but please
follow me once again the top left corner
so here we have our training script
Rosetta username Rosetta
about me Germany and so on then we're
going to get the existing data set we
keep the data set into bigquery we get
the data set then we're going to get the
new data why because we execute this
around every two days so if I'm dealing
with user names I'm going to get all the
usernames that has been created in the
last 48 hours then I'm going to create
another way all these dialects in
bigquery once again so I'm going to
create my new training set and then
we're going to train and here during
training we're going to clean the data
set this is automatically please it's
going to clean the data set is going to
find the best hyper parameter is going
to do plan magic when this is done we're
going to create one Kafka message again
everything here is Kafka and this
message is going to say like hey this
model has been trained
this was the accuracy good luck with it
and then each single component is going
to retrieve it's going to consume this
message for example Rosetta is going to
consume the message and when this
happened something cool is going to
happen here when we train we're actually
going to save the model into cloud
storage but what do I mean by saving the
model well in the case of logit we know
that logic is basically two things
coefficients and intercept so we're
going to store the coefficients and
intercept including to cloud storage but
we need a third thing here since I'm
dealing with data with text data and
dealing with a dictionary because I'm
actually using count vectorizer
to convert my my object my text into
numbers so I'm going to store my
dictionary coefficients and intercept so
the end Rosetta is going to retrieve
this and it's going to read this file
and it's going to do some magic that we
wrote and it's going to convert this
into a goal and logistic regression
model so that's the magic step that's
going to take a model from Python and
put it in to go along because we don't
want anything in python because the
coding is quite fast so then we have the
model and we're going to wrote the
production model and the new one in
parallel thing is going to happen more
magic basically some counts on something
called a Jensen Shannon divergence and
this is one statistic that is going to
measure
similar two distributions are and at the
air after some hours we're going to
check with the test model if the new one
is better than the production one then
we're going to replace it and then after
some hours the whole loop is going to
start now so numbers almost at the end
this is how the spammer percentage
should look like and recording daily at
the future this is data from the first
quarter the third quarter of 2016 and
the last the first quarter of this year
I have enough data in the numbers so
sorry about that now what happen here as
you can see in the percentage of span
user isn't below 1% which is amazing it
is called the same boring table for this
one is better the average time it takes
to punish someone and this is a
rollercoaster of emotions
at first it was horrible to one 2.2
hours
then got better 1.1 but then something
happen here I have no idea
2.4 it went up and down and down and
currently we are in around 0.7 so it's
been changing a lot so now recap on
conclusion spammers are bad that is good
a combination of ml and heuristic help
us in the fight and I think this is
really important here because a mark I
cannot believe a loading things reading
by hand that's what we have a lot of
hand read and ruled and our first deep
learning model k-much only like 3 months
ago which was the tracer so I think that
if we use both of them you know it's
going to be really nice and services
such cool cloud ml energy bigquery
assist us a lot and for the future we
would like to finish the conviction we
would like to do more image processing
for example we don't have nudity
detection something really simple sorry
someone up the wand
big peak can I say that then the person
are just going to be free in the app and
then lastly we want to do something
called the ante and this pan detector we
here our goal is to know if a user is
100% real so we don't touch the user and
then we avoid further false positive and
this is the sad part thanks a lot for
your time
say no to spam this is the repo of coca
and this go lonk of caffeine and you
know now you can applaud
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right thank you guys we have time
for two questions we have just one mic
so if you want to could I repeat the
question
hi you're a bad guy yeah still get a bad
guy yeah we have that yeah I mean we
have the but you know it does actually
determine later we have like a billion
gazillion IP but you know it's quite
silly analytically mati when you know
there's a spawn wave and just add the IP
and that's it you know - doesn't seem
more interesting but no nothing every
single cases is that because you know a
spammer like the really smart ones they
change their IPs and they owned like I'm
not I'm not lying they could own like a
thousand different IPS because they also
use ipv6 so you know it's it's like it's
like the load the low-hanging fruit cool
next yeah thank you so I have a question
how do you collect the ground truth so
naughty yes so not to make it say in a
circle how much time do I have for this
question Jesus how okay so geez man okay
well it's been like a long story because
when I join the company everything was
based on rules so you kind of start
building on that you know for example if
you know that I user does 40,000 likes
then it's a spammer but besides do you
like this person come from one place
this person has an IP this person have
this execution ratio so you keep
building on that things there's
something that sometimes we do it sounds
horrible but I call it eating our own
[ __ ] so sometimes we cannot train using
our own labels but we have to be a
hundred percent sure that this person is
actually like that so there's not an
actual answer for
but it's been a process of building on
your own things and a lot of tweaking
here a lot of cooking there but since
we're talking about Buda then sure you
could have some false positive some bad
example but at the end of the day it's
not really gonna matter it matters but
we have never had like any big big issue
so I mean to summarize the question it's
being a lot of work yeah I don't have
like a real answer because it's being a
process that we've been working for like
three years already
and there's some on our label or so